merci de me présenter à la porte B15
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis Romy
Allen votre commande de bord notre temps
de vol est estimé à 6 heures et 54
minutes
[Musique]
personne ne bouge tout à fait
l'opération a été lancée téléphone
tablette l'avion est sous contrôle
venez voir
quelqu'un envoie un appel au secours
vous avez de la famille des enfants
on m'a envoyé un message depuis l'avion
papa écrit incident à bord Ton père il
fait quoi exactement dans la vie c'est
difficile à expliquer il y a pas
meilleur que lui dans son domaine mais
il fait quoi de la négociation
[Musique]
il doit y avoir à peu près 200 passagers
dans cet avion si l'un d'entre temps
quelque chose et que cet avion s'écrase
je le regrette pas ma famille
alors voilà ce que je vous propose
on m'a remis des instructions si c'est
la pagaille de la première heure de vol
imaginer les six prochaines il faut
qu'on transmette un message à tous les
passagers que tout le monde se tienne
prêt
il y a des choses qui se préparent cinq
passagers de ce vol n'existent pas c'est
un réseau qui s'étend à travers toute
l'Europe
pour eux on est amis
soit eux soit nous
et je peux vous assurer que ce sera pas
nous
[Musique]